[Musique]
nous sommes le 1er décembre 2050 et
l'afrique
à l'instar des états unis d'amérique est
devenu un état fédéral composé de 54
pays
ce grand état est la cinquième puissance
économique mondiale devant le royaume
uni et la france
le continent s'est pleinement développé
les écoles sont performantes
les universités sont parmi les meilleurs
du monde
il y à des hôpitaux à la pointe partout
et donc l'espérance de vie s'est accrue
les africains dénigrent plus en masse à
la recherche du bonheur
non ce sont les peuples de tous les
autres continents qui a conversé de
terre qui les accueillent
chaleureusement
selon l'hospitalité légendaire qu'on lui
connaît les meilleurs chercheurs les
meilleurs cerveaux les meilleurs
ingénieurs se bousculent pour venir y
travailler dans les budgets alloués à la
recherche et au développement sont
illimitées et vous tous ceux qui
viennent ne viennent pas que pour le
tourisme
ils viennent aussi et surtout pour les
emplois pour les opportunités d'affaires
pour les conditions de vie on ne peut
plus agréable que le continent offre
désormais et oui nous y sommes arrivés
mais ça n'a pas été évident tout
semblait même perdu d'avancé
et pourtant tout avait bien commencé
l'afrique est reconnu comme étant le
berceau de l'humanité mais
l'esclavagé et la colonisation ont causé
des préjudices énormes au développement
du continent
après la colonisation au moment des
indépendances au début des années 1960
la france puisque c'est d'elle dont je
répare né qui a colonisé 14 pays en
afrique voulait garder la mainmise sur
les richesses de ses ex-colonies tant
elles sont vitales pour son
développement et son positionnement
stratégique dans le concert des nations
et pour ce faire elle a donc imposé à la
tête de ces nouveaux états des
présidents plus porté vers la
préservation des intérêts financiers
économiques stratégie de français que
vers le développement et le bien-être de
leur population
ces présidents manie avec une dextérité
inouïe la politique du bâton
c'est à dire refuser d'entendre les
populations et les réprimer un souhait
lorsqu'elle cessé de revendiquer le
minimum vital
c'est ainsi que des dictatures se sont
donc installés à la tête des ex colonies
françaises battant ainsi des records de
longévité au pouvoir
cinquante ans au gabon au togo
père et fils se succédant au pouvoir
dont des pays qui sont pas des
monarchies qui sont censés être des
républiques
tout ceci aurait pu paraître anecdotique
si derrière il n'y avait pas des
millions d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
qui vivent dans un énorme paradoxe leur
pays sont immensément riche
en matière première mais un sont
extrêmement pauvres avec des oligarchies
des responsables politiques dont la
richesse ne peut même pas être décrite
ils ont des biards dans tous les pays du
monde
si la l'ex puissance coloniale la france
a sa part de responsabilité dans cette
tragédie
on ne saurait dédouaner ses dirigeants
africains qui s'enrichissent de façon si
insolente tout en côtoyant
quotidiennement et dans l'indifférence
la plus totale
la misère de leurs compatriotes misère
qu'ils créent d'ailleurs et entretien
c'est dans mon pays le gabon que ce
paradoxe atteint son paroxysme
le gabon c'est harvey l'institut en
afrique centrale
il produit le pétrole le manganèse
l'uranium plus de 60% du territoire est
recouvert d'une forêt dense équatoriale
il a plus de 800 kilomètres de côtes
avec l'océan atlantique
et pourtant dans ce pays et qui ne
compte qu'un million 800 mille habitants
70% du territoire et de la population
vit en dessous du seuil de pauvreté 2 %
de la population se partage en 90 % des
richesses du pays le pays manque de tout
faux
vous avez là une route à l'intérieur du
gabon en 2018 pays producteurs de
pétrole dans la capitale libreville et
dans le reste du pays d'ailleurs dans
les maternités les femmes accouchent à
même le sol et vous pouvez voir ici des
bébés des nouveau-nés posé par terre
dans une maternité
j'ai grandi à libreville dans un
quartier défavorisé chez nous ces
quartiers défavorisés les appelle les
matitis où le mât panne ça ressemble à
ça à ma peine en 2018 à libreville au
gabon pays producteur de pétrole mais
les avoirs de la famille présidentielle
qui tient le pays depuis près de 50 ans
s'élève à plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros seulement en france
dans mon quartier
nous n'avions pas d'eau dans les
domiciles
il fallait parcourir des centaines de
mètres voire des kilomètres tout dépend
de la distance à laquelle se situer la
pompe public c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelait dans laquelle il fallait aller
puiser de l'eau tous les jours pour tout
faire et en 2018
la vie n'a toujours pas changé dans le
matin on va encore à la pompe public
peut puiser de l'eau dans ce contexte
mes parents
m'avait appris que la seule façon de
s'en sortir
c'était nous considérer l'école
communication sociale alors je voulais
apprendre
j'aimais l'école mais dans mon quartier
il n'y avait rien pas une bibliothèque
pas un centre de lecture pas mam en
collège
juste un rappel un million huit cent
mille habitants le pétrole le manganèse
l'uranium et il m'arrivait de faire 20
km à pied pour partir et revenir de
l'école à seulement 12 13 ans et quand
j'ai eu 15 ans parce que j'aimais à
prendre et que j'aimais faire apprendre
vous avez en classe quand les
professeurs explique l iphone disait et
compte que les élèves -neuf semblait ne
pas avoir compris le professeur me
disait laurent c'est ce que tu peux
réexpliqué et je ré expliquer et mes
camarades me disait toi tu va se finir
profs et j'ai donc décidé d'être prof
parce que c'est ce que je savais faire
j'ai su que j'avais envie de faire je
suis donc sorti de l'école normale
supérieure de libreville en 1996 j'ai
été affecté dans un lycée de la banlieue
nord chez nous quand on dit lycée il ya
le collège et le lycée dans le même
établissement et dans mon établissement
va vous la moyenne le nombre d'élèves
par classe aussi entre 50 et 100 et
quand vous pouvez le voir sur cette
extraire de rapports de fin d'année de
2014 2015 l'année scolaire 2014 2015
dans le même établissement
on en est à près de 200 elle a plus de
200 élèves par classe ça ne s'est pas
amélioré sa empirer
imaginez le sentiment de frustration
imaginez le sentiment d'impuissance que
l'on peut avoir
lorsqu'on doit exercer son métier dans
des conditions aussi exécrable imaginez
dans quel état j'ai pu me trouver face à
des élèves qui tentait de se suicider
juste pour échapper aux conditions de
vie trop difficile qui étaient les leurs
et tout ça dans un pays qui a pourtant
tout pour pourvoir à leurs besoins
alors pour ne plus voir cette misère et
pour contribuer un tant soit peu à ce
que les richesses de mon pays et soient
équitablement répartis
qu'il y ait un minimum de justice
sociale j'ai décidé de m'engager dans la
lutte contre la confiscation du pouvoir
par les dictatures avec son corollaire
la mal gouvernance
parce qu'en réalité il confie ce que le
pouvoir juste pour voler
c'est ainsi qu'au début de l'année 2016
prenant mon courage à deux mains
j'ai écrit un ouvrage gabon pourquoi
j'accuse pour dénoncer d'une part la
tragédie dans laquelle vit mon peuple et
aussi pour que les générations futures
sachent ce par quoi nous sommes passés
mais aussi dans ce livre je propose des
solutions pour améliorer la gouvernance
de mon pays et depuis je n'ai pas arrêté
je parcours les plateaux de télévision
les radios les conférences pour que l'on
sache ce que nous vivons est surtout que
les responsables soient reconnus pour ce
qu'ils sont c'est à dire des bourreaux
des tyrans le 27 août 2016 il y avait
une élection présidentielle dans mon
pays le gabon est comme toutes les
autres élections
les résultats étaient tronquées ils ont
simplement été inversés et le dictateur
qui avait en réalité perdu l'élection a
été proclamé vainqueur
les populations sont sorties dans les
rues pour manifester leur mécontentement
elles ont simplement été réprimée dans
le sang
et ils ont poussé la répression très
loin parce qu'ils ont programmée
planifier et exécuter une attaque
militaire sur des civils non armés dans
la nuit du 31 août
ils ont encerclé le quartier général de
campagne de celui qui avait gagné
l'élection présidentielle
et là les militaires ont tiré à bout
portant sur des gens et depuis cet
endroit une femme de plus de 70 ans m'a
appelé la nuit du 31 août à 3 heures du
matin et elle murmuré à me disait tu vas
vis et derrière j'entendais les cris
j'entendais les coups de feu et ensuite
les silences nous sortir de cette
élection
celui qui avait perdu dans son ministre
de la communication annonce sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'il vient en france
pour participer à un forum sur le
numérique
tollé sur les réseaux sociaux campagne
sur twitter est secrétaire d'état au
numérique de l'époque afin communiqué
pour dire qu'il ne viendrait plus qu'il
n'était pas attendue à pareille la même
année le dictateur qui était maintenu au
pouvoir a été nominé par une
organisation américaine figurez vous
pour recevoir le prix du citoyen de
l'année
pareille mobilisation sur les réseaux
sociaux il a été retiré de la liste des
nominés
alors ces petites victoires ont
encouragé les activistes et les
défenseurs pro droits humains à mener de
plus belle leur lutte
sachant que maintenant il avait de
nouvelles armes internet et les réseaux
sociaux
c'est pour ça que quand j'ai entendu
parler du de différents lyon le 1er
décembre 2018
je me suis dit il faut que j'y aille
et je suis là et cette conférence de
tweets du tmx elle d'un apport capital
dans notre combat parce que toutes les
personnes ici présentes prennent
conscience de ce qu'elles peuvent
contribuer elles peuvent avoir un apport
fondamental pour mettre fin aux
dictatures et inciter à la bonne
gouvernance en faisant quoi me direz
vous en faisant de petites actions toute
simple poster relayer des tweets signer
des pétitions être plus attentifs aux
relations de la france avec ses
ex-colonies interpellé vos élus locaux
et nationaux pour que cesse le soutien
de la france aux dictatures parce que
voyez-vous le monde est devenu
planétaire
la misère ne peut plus rester que d'un
côté elle finit par arriver jusqu'à nous
on a aujourd'hui l'exemple des migrants
qui sont là on parle de en termes de
quotas mais on oublie les tragédies qui
les pousse à partir alors l'afrique est
arrivé en 2050
elle s'est développée mais sa grâce au
concours de l'ensemble des citoyens du
monde qui se sont mobilisés et qui ont
donc oeuvré grâce à internet qui se sont
sentis concernés et en 2050 l'afrique
est devenue sont grands états développés
pour tous
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 1er décembre
nous allons y arriver grâce à votre
pouvoir grâce au pouvoir de tous les
citoyens du monde
alors à vous de jouer merci
on est là c'est bien